joining us now from MLB Network from Fox
Sports I think I was a little harsh
earlier to baseball I love baseball
brockman knows that John Morosi knows
that who joins us on the phone as well
hi John how are you
outstanding Andrew greetings from a
Sunsplash afternoon here in Clearwater
Florida
affiliates and Jays I just watched Bryce
Harper as first half out of the ballgame
here so how's that for a baseball seemed
to set there it is hard to be upset
about anything in spring trees on that
sounds amazing thank you for painting a
picture for us can you please tell us
Bryce Harper's walk-up music that is a
great question so I was actually I was
mid conversation with with the gentleman
next to me with one who's batting so I
can actually mention that and I will say
this even even then sometimes my my
modern music references are a little
slow and actually I get all that fluency
whatever little I have Andrew no idea I
will tell my wife hey have you heard
this before no but I have because I'm at
the stadium therefore I'm up on I had
the conversation all the time it's
usually in the newsroom at NFL Network
somebody mentions an artist and I say I
have no idea
yes you do it's that song and I I don't
know yes you do okay John Merrow see now
calling in from a Phillies game in
Florida John has Dallas Keuchel signed
yet he has not and in fact I was I was
told yesterday at last check he was
throwing a two hitters in in North
Newport Beach California at the Boras
sports fitness Institute that is run by
his agent Scott Boras so he's I think
that the possibilities there the Astros
the Braves who are now a bit concerned
about Mike Fulton Davis the news of
course came today also about Louis
Severino with the Yankees being out so I
think we'd have to maintain those three
teams as being at least possible suitors
for Dallas Keuchel John tell me or tell
the laymen out there why Keuchel and
Kimbrel and Gio Gonzales the list goes
on tell them why they're not signed I
think that the reasons are a little
unique to each player I think
the case of Kimbrel he was coming off of
a postseason that was not his best work
he was given up some loud contact at
different times during the playoffs and
so he's coming off of a bit of a
disappointing playoffs and at a time
when the general position of closer is
not quite valued the way that it used to
be he's also right around the age of 30
which we've seen teams now regard a
little bit differently in terms of
valuating there so I think he probably
his agent probably was asking too for
too much too early about where things
actually we're gonna settle out with the
market there so I think he probably
would have been better served to sign a
little bit earlier in the calendar as
for Keuchel and geo I think on some
level Andrew they're both represented by
Scott Boras I think they just based on
the bandwidth of Scott's offseason he
was pretty tied up with number three
here in Clearwater and getting bright
side and I think that there was a bit of
a sequential way about his his
procedures that I think maybe as part of
the reason why it was waiting until
February or March to get geo and Dallas
Keuchel time talking to John Merrow see
who's actually at a Phillies game in
Florida joining us on the phone here on
the Rich Eisen show John from MLB
Network and Fox I'm Andrew Siciliano
sitting in for Rich Eisen when you look
at these rules or the agreement that the
the Union and Major League Baseball John
hit Send on yesterday morning and sent
out some of them this year
some of them next year what's the one
that jumps out to you because I know
what jumps out to me but I want to know
what's the one that jumps out to you I
think for fans watch the game Andrew
it's gonna be the three batter minimum
face or all pitchers to face and it's
important to point out too that one of
the unique aspects of that rule is it's
either three batters or the end of the
half inning so you can still play the
matchup game if you're confident in that
pitchers ability to get to last out of
the inning and then be replaced during
the inning frame so that's that's one
key part of the of the deal I think a
couple things number one it's important
to me that MLB in the Union are working
being meaningfully on changes that that
they hope and believe could result in a
quicker pace to the game and a better
hello to the game which we all around
baseball want to see I hear Andrew that
this this has been arrived at because
they believe that this will help and I
think if it ends up not helping
I think they'll change and they'll
they'll revert back to it I think the
important thing here is more to me
Andrew somatic than it is the specifics
of this this is this is a the beginning
of a conversation or rather continuing
one that began with the bouncing other
things but actually have not been all
that interested of the game at all and
it's just allowing both parties to
manage what's happening in the change of
the game I realized that this ball the
rules have been sacrosanct for a very
long time but the important thing here
is Andrew that that'll be in the Union
are both collectively saying you know
what there are things happening and the
trends of the game that we don't like
let's get together let's talk about it
I'll full three seasons before this
basic agreement is over all right John
I hear you and I understand that the
game has to evolve all games evolve
sports evolve I mean what used to be a
ground rule double or rather I mean what
we now call a ground rule double used
two years ago be a home run there used
to be no three-point line in basketball
I get it and I also get that this rule
doesn't go into effect until 2020 let me
spell it out for those who don't know
the office of the Commissioner will
implement an amended rule requiring that
starting pitchers and relief pitchers
must pitch to either a minimum of three
batters or end of a half inning with
exceptions for people that get injured
or ill John I think it's the dumbest
thing I've ever heard
to be blunt like let's say you're
bringing a reliever and there's one out
and he gives up back-to-back home runs
and there's still only one out I got to
keep him in for it for the interest of
keeping a Millenial interested i I just
it you're fundamentally changing the
game if I'm take it from a football
perspective if I bring a running back in
on third down does he have to carry the
ball before he leaves do I have to have
an intended pass at his feet
I realize John it's not your job to
defend your you're not the witness on
the stand here
I just think it's it's fundamentally
changing the game and I I understand as
well that I sound like a guy who's in
his mid-40s who wants it like it was
when he was a kid and I don't want to be
stuck in the mud and stuck in the past
but it just sounds stupid well again
there are some very valid concerns there
about what happens if a guy is just
really does not have his stuff and gives
up a couple of home runs what then
happens and that's a fair point I would
say a couple things on that number one
that place is in my judgment a premium
on effective relievers who can get both
righties and lefties out which i think
actually in my judgment does a better
job of putting the best representative
clubs on the field of the truly most
talented pitchers in baseball I think
the best relievers the best pitchers are
those that have success against both
righties and lefties and and so maybe
this is now squeezing out some of the
quote unquote DeLuca's the left of the
left on left one out guys and they're
probably going to start moving out of
the game on some level and that's
unfortunate for them but I also think
it's now valuing and rewarding those
relievers who can pitch consistently for
a long period of time at least for at
least one full inning that's that's
really important I think it's an overall
scope of the game you're rewarding that
talent I also think in general we add
your point earlier we've changed the
game before that the D H changed the
game probably even more than this change
is changing the game so it's and it's
the key thing I get into it I circle
back to this this is something that
they're trying out because the current
trend in MLB has a lot of marketing data
as the commissioners talked about in the
past it says that one thing that turns
people off late in the game a lot of
pitching changes the bad bet is a drag
on the time and it end it all and often
they've found it makes people quite
literally tuned out late in the ball
game this they hope will address some of
that issue and keep the game moving
along because the way that it's gone
Andrew that the current passive things
all the strikeouts that the homerun
strikeout the lack of contact that part
of the game has I believe in the way
that I grew up watching it takes a lot
of the action taking a lot of the action
away from baseball
and they hope that this restores some of
that action and and brings a little bit
more as it's been said before it's not
so much the pace of the game but the
pace of the action they want more action
they hope and expect this will bring
more action and if it does not and you I
believe that they will very quickly
unchanged it because this is a very much
a dynamic discussion and not in any way
a final change to the working rules of
Asia and John what about this what was
was this ever discussed when you bring a
guy in from the bullpen no warmup
pitches like if you're in the pen and
you're warming up to get ready to go in
the game then when you take the mound
you should be ready because that's a way
and that's a fundamental change as well
but that is a way to potentially speed
things up
did that ever get on the table not to my
knowledge and it's a fair point though
because in general we have we in the
game we have seen the diminishment in
the amount of warmup time that there's
now been a little stricter guidelines on
how much time a pitcher has to get
warmed up they've actually done a pretty
good job of compressing that time in
general but I think to go totally
without a warmup
I think would kind of get into the realm
of are you risking pitcher injury
pitchers that for their whole lives been
conditioned to have a bit of a warm-up
time before they begin and ending so I
think for that they would probably say
it would probably have a negative impact
on overall pitcher health and
performance frankly not on the field
alright John Rossi speaking strictly as
a fan of the Cleveland Indians now have
we reached we past the point where
Kluber or Bauer is going to be traded or
do I just should I call you back at the
end of July yeah I would say for now
Andrew you are safe okay
sumit they're gonna be on your opening
day roster I think even when they
reported for spring training that that
possibility was was to me swept away but
I would say this while you do not have
to worry about that I think you do have
to worry about the Minnesota Twins the
twins are good and I visited their camp
here earlier this month was very
impressed they had a very quietly
effective offseason they added a lot of
good veteran names Nelson Cruz Marwin
Gonzalez
Jonathan scope CJ Crone they're gonna
mash his head there I didn't score a ton
of runs I think it's gonna be a great
match
to watch that offense go up against the
Cleveland pitching staff I've taken the
twins this year and ruined the central
maybe it's just a bit of a variant pick
but I like what they're doing right now
so I would say Bower and Cooper are on
your team but I'm not sure that your
team is gonna win the division right now
all right one more self-serving question
come 2022 how big is Francisco Lindor s
contract Oh
massive I mean I you could you can make
that you can make the argument that
based on pure value that he is a more
valuable player than Bryce Harper now I
don't know if you look at the osteo
donfield conversation but based on his
performance positional value shortstop
switch hitter what he does oh my
goodness uh III think that he will sign
if as long as he continued on his friend
his contract will be for greater than
250 now maybe the something for him with
Bryce is he's gonna be a little bit
older than Bryce when history agency but
I think that his total value should be
around the 250 billion dollar range for
Francis Kobe's daughter well thankfully
I don't have to wait until 2022
everything could be thrown out there
I am roughly my papers John I've been
told to not do that in front of the
microphone so I'm gonna set that aside
and thank you kindly as always for
joining the program enjoy Florida and be
sure to wear sunscreen sounds great my
friend always great catching up and I
look forward to watching your like why
Sir John Rosie from Fox and from MLB
Network the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience